همم طبعا يعني انا هنا في هذه المنطقه
بدات منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه المسيره للعمال
المطربين عن العمل من مختلف القطاعات
بداوا من منطقه وهم متجهين الان الى مقر
الحكومه في صن داونز 3 اترك الصوره لتشاهد
هذه المسيره طبعا فيها يعني نقبات تابعه
لقطاع التعليم هناك نقابات تابعه للنقل
وايضا نرى نقابات تابعه لمختلف القطاعات
من همم الخدمه المدنيه طبعا هذا القطاع
الذي يضرب همم اليوم يشمل حوالي 100,000
موظف وعامل من مختلف الدوائر الحكوميه
حوالي ال 133 دائره وكاله حكوميه منهم خبر
السواحل منهم حارس الحدود همم يعني همم
الذين طبعا يحل محلهم عناصر من الجيش طبعا
هناك الى جانب اضراب عمال المدنيه هناك
اضراب للمعلمين هذا الاضراب هو الاكبر منذ
حوالي ثلاثه عقود يشارك فيه نحو المئه الف
معلم ومن يعني المتوقع ان يؤثر على حوالي
23 الف مدرسه في مختلف انحاء انجلترا
وويلز طبعا يعني نحن نعلم بان النقابات
تطالب برفع الوجود يقولون بان ساعات العمل
طويله الرواتب تكفي عشرات الالاف من هؤلاء
بحسب النقابات يعتمدون باتوا على بنوك
الطعام وبالتالي هم غير قادرين على تحمل
تكاليف واعباء الحكومه طبعا هذه المسيره
التي نراها تمتدي حوالي البضعه كيلومترات
تتجه نحو مقر الحكومه في تان دا من
المتوقع ان يكون هناك احتجاج لهؤلاء
مطالبه الحكومه برفع الوجود نحن انا
الحكومه ملتزمه او يعني همم ملتزمه
بموقفها همم
الذي يقول بانهم يعني بان الحكومه غير
قادره او لا لا يوجد المال الكافي لتحقيق
مطالب